what do you know about Steven
Crowder um I know that he was a he's
quite controversial yeah is he's like a
strict Christian is he strict yeah I
don't know yeah and uh advocate for
marriage yeah so well he was he was he
was he was oh no what happened so
Crowder um really I would say did
everything right he he actually waited
till he was married with his wife MH um
to have sex and that actually made like
headlines back in the day oh my God yeah
and he he ends up um doing the
traditional conservative route and he
gets married and he has two kids um
about six to eight months ago
now his wife released ring footage
accusing him of abuse oh no basically
Crowder and the daily wire were fighting
about a contract Crowder kind of pissed
off some people at the daily wire okay
so Crowder basically comes out and says
that he's divorcing or him and his wife
are getting divorced and he's being
blackmailed by the daily wire they they
deny this they say this is not true but
two days later Candace Owens releases
ring footage from his private residence
way and says that and has a video titled
stepen Crowder is a monster no way yes
yes so I I don't know if he was or he
wasn't and then she says this is
preposterous I can't believe you accuse
me of this I'm only releasing this
because you said that you're you're at
you're playing the victim here you're
you're acting like your wife is in the
wrong divorcing you um why she doesn't
get to give her side of the story I'll
let her her give her side of the story
on my platform wow she releases ring
footage accusing Crowder of abuse sugar
and the thing is me because I I I know
these type of cases I knew what she was
doing whenever these chicks release ring
footage to the public it's like why is
why are you why are you like you never
know the reasoning behind the clip MH
and months later I find out like I I
have a source reach out to me and give
me the full context behind the clip in
the clip he basically says to his wife
you need to listen to me and he was kind
of being moany and like whining at her
about it and then she says he goes into
the house and says I'll [__] you up so
that sounds like abuse I get the
recorded version with the full footage
in the house and right after he says I'm
sorry I'm sorry too
far wow so is that really the abusive
and they left that bit out obviously yes
yes and the thing is Candace never
reported the new information and so all
of conservative Twitter and in like she
ruined his reputation accusing him of
abuse all of this stuff and really and
then I get the affidavit later where she
admits in court he was not abusive
Candace Owens no not Candace the wife
sorry the wife later admits in court
that he was not abusive okay but the
damage has been done the damage has been
done that was the whole point and it was
unfortunate because I love Candace Owens
but she was just so wrong in this and I
don't know why the daily wire hasn't
issued a retraction or at least reported
on the new
information um but regardless um
regardless so Crowder before he was
married
had a very different tune on the men
that fear
marriage and right now there's a clip
going viral of his changes in tune after
this whole thing let's pull it up we've
talked about this a lot the incels right
the involuntary celibates the
professionally outraged over alimon and
child support payment crowd sorry I'm
not on board with you you know what you
need to learn to be the person that your
woman's going to want when wolves are at
the
[Music]
door
yeah and and that's the thing like they
think we're celebrating and we're not
we're not celebrating like I would never
celebrate this sort of thing but it's
like you don't know until you know
exactly I mean that's it's horrible for
him to do that to fellow men like just
because he hasn't been through yet and
then w
uh now he knows he's red
pilled have you seen this before uh the
Steven Crowder thing yeah um I actually
did see the footage but even then I was
just like you have to see the whole
thing don't do not just give us a clip
of that because obviously and we know
the bigger picture why they're doing it
what the plan but the average Layman
would be like oh yeah see he said
something you know in a you know
questionable tone but that's not good
enough now you know we need to see the
full picture well and the other thing is
he was assuming he said just be the
person your wife needs you to be
something like that he's assuming we're
reasonable people yeah yeah like we're
not guys you know what I mean you know
I'm like you're assuming the woman that
they married is reasonable yeah and so
now you have this girl she waited till
she was married she was a Christian she
was thin she was beautiful
like yeah but what else was he supposed
to do he found the good woman that
prayed and
then so I I was more asking though have
you know being in the work that you do
um how do you see men typically get red
pill oh uh exactly like this exactly
like this a lot of times they would be
like um you know oh uh they're so in
love with their wife and being a husband
and everything and then they just think
guys are being bitter or being
overreactive and then they go in they go
through it and they're just like
suddenly they just realize everything is
against them yeah and then they you know
it's like a growing list it's like a
growing club yeah of people who like you
know wow I I had no idea and and they
learned the lesson the hard way and it's
sad it's very sad because most of the
time I I always hear well they shouldn't
sleep around and do all this stuff but
in my experience and maybe you might
have a different one it is not the men
that slept around and were like complete
[__] and all that stuff that this
happens to no it's actually mostly the
men that want to do the right thing
absolutely my god I've spoken to more
like I would say I've spok to so many
men who have been a good devoted husband
and and and this is not just me being
biased I'm extremely objective about
this by the way and there are a lot of
women who even go through difficulties
we're not dening that whatsoever but it
is so
astronomically men who suffer and and it
it's so sad because they are so innocent
in terms of yeah you know I I want to be
a good father I want to be a good
husband and they just get so just just
backhanded by their wife or their
girlfriend or whatever and then um and
then the system being that you're in law
school and there's a lot of lawyers that
actively like sign up to do this you
know how does this happen like like what
what's your experience and like what
circumstances create these situations
money it's all about money money
absolutely I think back when in the 80s
or 90s back then um like that's when
lawyers law firms were actually paying
attention to the family court system
before then they didn't
really it wasn't really um common for
law firms to have a family court section
where they family law yeah because it
wasn't lucrative back then but now it's
such big business that every single law
fir has a you know not every single one
but mainly now it's the norm to have a
family law section and because obviously
the house the house is the biggest asset
and so if you get that sold big money
guaranteed
guaranteed and that's why the men never
get the house yeah never yeah very rare
cases I've never heard of a guy getting
the house yeah I I can't think of why
and you know what's interesting they
call them incels but they have kids I
know that's I'm like they're like these
bitter incels I'm like inels wouldn't
even get in the door with I they're
having flipping loads of children and
stuff like again I find that the typical
archetype of the men that I've
interviewed is a guy that has a normal
job and really just wants to be a father
and do the right thing yeah it's not
these it's not these guys that are
getting all the ladies if anything thing
I would say and i' I've talked to a
couple men that were like you know
high-end business owners athletes or
whatever that went through the same
thing but I would say if I had to guess
those guys can keep the women a little
bit better than the average man yeah if
I if I had to guess